covert 19 has brought disruption to the
globalized and interconnected world
the challenges of kovid have led to a
dark period
both in terms of human suffering but
also the damage done to of political and
social fabric
but before the pandemic globalization
was already in retreat
now that trend looks set to accelerate
this is a diminished world in many ways
that we're looking at
it's a world of globalization
[Music]
from smartphones to toys today's
globalized trading system has grown to
rely on long and complex supply chains
but the pandemic has played havoc with
them
clothing is one industry that has been
hit hard
worth 2.5 trillion dollars globally it
employs over 43 million people
in asia alone one of the most footloose
industries when it comes to supply chain
has always been the garment industry
that's because it has a high level of
human involvement
and so the labor cost of a product is
much higher than you might find in an
automobile for example
for that reason we've always seen
companies chase the lowest cost
[Music]
that means manufacturing mostly happens
in asia
and the global nature of the industry
makes it especially vulnerable to
disruptions
take a typical pair of trousers sold on
a high street in western europe
the label says made in bangladesh but
many of the parts come from other
countries
chinese factories making buttons and
zips shut during the pandemic
meaning the items didn't reach their
next port
factories in bangladesh couldn't finish
the trousers
and canceled orders to cotton suppliers
in india
and lockdown hit demand in the west as
customers weren't shopping on high
streets
in america clothing sales fell by 73.5
percent
between march and april this year
bangladesh lost out on an estimated 3.2
billion dollars from cancelled exports
in just six months
and across asia millions of low-income
workers were laid off
goods taking long journeys from factory
to the high street have become one of
the signatures of globalization
[Music]
the roots of today's heavily globalized
world were put down at the end of the
second world war
the allied nations created a rules-based
system for international commerce and
finance
designed to establish the economic
foundations of peace
on the bedrock of genuine international
cooperation
this allowed companies products science
and technology
to move across borders
then in the 1990s the world entered an
era of hyper globalization
becoming more interconnected than ever
before
a dream of money money
in this era the big new player on the
scene was china
which joined the world trade
organization
it grew to dominate global trade
alongside the united states
multinational companies thrived
expanding into china
and all over the globe
from 1990 to 2008 the total trade in
goods and services increased
from 39 to 61 of world gdp
this great globalization boom enabled a
billion people in developing countries
to lift themselves out of poverty
and in the west consumers enjoyed
cheaper and more accessible travel and
goods
[Music]
covert 19 struck a major blow to
unfettered globalization
but before the pandemic arrived
globalization had already taken two
other big hits the american financial
system
is rocked to its foundation japanese
stocks down nine percent the hong kong
market's down
everywhere you look the color is red and
no one it seems
can stop the bleeding the first was the
2008 financial crisis
when cross-border investment trade bank
loans and supply chains
shrank globalization started to slow
down
a process known as globalization
the global financial crisis decade ago
was perhaps an
early sign of the beginnings of
globalization
it wasn't recognized as such at the time
because it seemed to be a banking crisis
the global economy suffered
[Music]
and those who had already lost out
during the heyday of globalization
felt even poorer opposition to the
system grew
and we see this kind of sentiment across
western democracies
to bring the jobs back that were stolen
when the factories moved particularly to
china
those who were left behind very cruelly
by the policies and people that
supported globalization
that is the blue-collar workers for
example in factories
in northern england or in the midwest of
america the trump voters
this desire to revive manufacturing and
bring back dignity to workers spread
across the western world
a wave of populist leaders were elected
across the globe
championing nationalist policies
attacking immigration
and the existing global economy
[Music]
[Music]
the future does not belong to globalists
the future belongs to patriots
[Music]
free trade went out of fashion and
protectionism was all the rage
the number of trade interventions such
as tariffs and subsidies
introduced by countries has been
increasing year on year
and while some have brought
liberalization most have been harmful to
world trade
in this climate globalization suffered a
second assault
[Music]
we can't continue to allow china
to rape our country and that's what
they're doing
a trade war blew up between the world's
two largest economies
for years the west had accused china of
flouting wto rules
saying its trading practices were unfair
to western companies
but president trump turned rhetoric into
policy
since the start of his presidency
tariffs on chinese exports to the u.s
have increased
six-fold china hit back more than
doubling its tariffs on u.s goods
the advent of the pandemic this year was
the third big disruption to
globalization
within the last 12 years globalization
has sped up
[Music]
this year the imf forecasts that global
gdp could fall by 4.9 percent
that is 50 times more than in 2009
the post-covert world is likely to be a
more fractious and regionalized one
what we saw for 20-30 years with
unfettered global trade with unfettered
global travel
with sourcing from china serving the
world i think we'll never go back to
that
what we're likely to see is a messier
world and future
one with elements of globalization
continuing
but many other counter trends that lead
to either regionalization
nationalization localization some form
of
de-globalization and so we're going to a
spiky world
we're going to see much more disruption
[Music]
multinationals try to navigate the
challenges of the pandemic
the talk in the boardroom is
increasingly about how to be less global
and more local they have seen
how vulnerable their supply chains are
to unanticipated disruption of a natural
kind
for the first time at the level of the
ceo and the board
companies are discussing supply chain
risk and what to do about it and how to
ensure against it
now they're seeing this as something
vital to the business
some companies are ahead of the game the
spanish clothing retailer zara
is one of the most successful in the
clothing industry
and its shorter supply chains have
helped the company
weather the coveted storm while most
western high street fashion brands have
offshored manufacturing to asia
where labour is cheaper distance equals
time
so retailers have to bulk order six
months in advance
and in that time a lot can go out of
fashion
zara keeps its manufacturing base closer
to home for its higher fashion lines
meaning you can take a design to the
high street in a matter of weeks
that way it doesn't stockpile inventory
and can respond quickly to consumer
trends
that model is coming to not just to
fashion but industry after industry is
going to move in that direction
in part because the on-demand economy is
allowing
us to express our tastes through social
commerce
we've seen a revolution that's driven
both by fear of disruption on one hand
but also by the opportunities created by
the internet economy
the pandemic has disrupted the movement
of goods people and capital around the
globe
but even without covert 19 another
pillar of globalization would be facing
challenges
the flow of data across borders
the great firewall of china has kept out
the likes of google and facebook for
years
[Music]
and president trump's recent attacks on
tiktok and wechat
are deepening this splinter net between
china and the west
we're looking at tick tock we may be
manning
and it's not just software we confronted
untrustworthy chinese technology and
telecom providers
we convinced many countries many
countries
and i did this myself for the most part
not to use huawei
the decoupling of chinese and american
tech also extends to hardware
i think this is likely to lead to two
worlds a china-dominated world
and an america-dominated world on
technology and software
and ultimately we will have less
innovation
the unpicking of globalization may
accelerate on a number of fronts
irrespective of when covert 19 is
brought under control
and this could be bad news for
developing countries such as india
[Music]
the globalization boom allowed countries
in southeast asia to rise to
middle-income status
but the likes of india may miss out on
this
there is a concern that we may see a
leap frogging in countries that are
emerging
the way that china had a chance to put
its massive population to work in
factories
there is a worry that for developing
countries that are just emerging at that
stage that the world may move to a
post-industrial economy
and leave them behind this is a genuine
concern
and they are not the only people who
stand to lose out from deglobalization
in rich countries like the us and
britain those most in favor of reigning
in globalization could suffer the most
we're going to london to stop the brexit
betrayal good morning
economic nationalism will not prove to
be a silver bullet
it's very likely that uh policies of
de-globalization or economic nationalism
that try to bring the factories back
will discover that you can bring the
factories back
but you can't bring the jobs back that's
because when the factories
are brought back almost always they will
be more highly automated
than they were in china but even as the
world becomes more de-globalized
some of the biggest winners from
globalization will endure
big digital companies like netflix
google and facebook
will keep getting bigger with the
pandemic accelerating the trend towards
shopping online
companies following the amazon model of
fast direct delivery
will also do well the top 10 percent
even in the worst sectors worst meeting
hardest hit sectors
could well emerge with a winning
business model i think in every crisis
you find some companies that fall behind
and those that are fundamentally able to
re-jig their business models
and innovate are the ones that thrive
in the post-covered world some aspects
of globalization affected by the
pandemic
may shift back such as freedom to travel
the world has grown too integrated for a
full unwinding of globalization
covert will not kill it off it will
deepen the cracks
however this may not be all bad news
i'm hopeful that we'll learn the right
lessons that we need to make our
societies more resilient
so that we don't resort to very simple
solutions that don't work
like shut down the supply chain build a
wall
keep the immigrants out we've tried
those things before
i think the broader solution is to make
interdependence
work with resilience that's the
challenge that
global leaders face today
[Music]
i'm vijay vadis warren u.s business
editor of the economist
if you'd like to find out more about the
topic of the pandemic and the global
economy
click on the link opposite thank you for
watching
and don't forget to subscribe